charlie morton takes the bound for the
braves and the final game of this series
trying to get the braves a series win
one and two for the marlins third
baseman and birdie didn't get the
breaking ball that's been his bread and
butter pitch
charlie morton gets birdie for strikeout
101
on the season
and there's that big breaking ball stays
in the strike zone in the first inning
and martay swings and misses
back-to-back swinging strikeouts
charlie's got good stuff early that was
97 miles an hour yeah good fast ball
there
and on the ground dansby to a knee
fields and fires and charlie morton had
a brilliant first inning three outs nine
pitches with a couple of strikeouts
zach thompson who's been terrific for
the marlins in his first five starts
this year yeah two and two with a 1-5
beat the braves like i said on the 12th
went five innings no runs six strikeouts
last time out
2-1 pitch to albie's sharply hit but the
marlins have the shift on in shallow
right it's birdie one two three innings
for both starters today
[Music]
at an era that cost miami a run but not
the game yesterday
and he ropes one into center and
makes a sliding catch
two bullets back to back but a nice grab
by guillermo
quick bet quick reactions and a great
result scoreless in the second
[Music]
bottom of the second
and the braves with a scoring
opportunity here for heredia who in 52
games has knocked in 18 runs
he's hitting 275. here's the pitch swing
and a miss thompson put him away
upstairs
he's going to go with the cut fastball
up
and it's a beauty on the black birdie
couldn't pull the trigger morton gives
up a hit but strikes out his fourth man
now the question is as morton pops one
into shallow right duval coming on he
can't get there can't find it
charlie morton with a blue pit
acuna with 22 home runs
he'll be starting in center field in the
all-star game
and hammer deep to right field at the
wall
it's out of here
big time bad flip for ronald lacuna
junior oh baby
the bat went as high as the ball over
the wall two nothing
that is a star spangled blast for ronald
acuna two-nothing braves
right into the first row of the
chop-outs
so 23 homers 50 rbis for acuna his first
hit of the series
[Applause]
and adam duvall with a line drive out to
left field
back in front of the wall archia makes
the play deep enough to score marty and
the marlins do
get on the board with the sac fly from
adam duvall
panic leads at first not going and
strike three of fastball he couldn't
pull the trigger 96 miles an hour
and a good sequence for charlie morton
and strike three seven strikeouts for
morton and two in a row here in the
fifth inning
now enter the mathematical second half
of the year marlins can
pick up a few more of those types of
wins
this is gonna squirt through a base hit
that's
true for a base hit
so back-to-back knocks for the marlins
here in the sixth inning
duval stands in a strikeout in a sac fly
and a fly ball out to left center field
hit well carrying and gone three run
home run adam duvall
he gets his former club again and the
marlins jump in front hell adam duvall
he absolutely loves that breaking ball
down
a huge three-run home run
as the marlins retake the lead
you'd love to get them all back right
here but one would
be awfully helpful
in the air to right that one curling
away from duval still going can't get it
it's over his head up against the wall
it's a two-out double for dansby swanson
26 of his 35 rbis have come at home the
braves do cash in and lead off walk and
we've got a one-run game again
thompson brings it home
and a cold strike three got the call on
the outside corner and he completes six
innings of work and with the lead
garcia two two count
and on the ground birdie can't cut it
off and garcia's got his first hit as a
brave
william contreras ground ball diving
stop by panic rojas and over to first
what a play by joe panic
takes a hit away and starts the 4-6-3
double play
yeah beautifully done by joe
a big play in this ball game
four runs and looking for more
aguilar smashes one into right field
and another lead off base runner for the
marlins here in the eighth inning
3.9 they are at four
and duval with the fly ball right field
and this one is a
fair ball yeah fair ball yeah it is
another home run for adam duvall
he's done it again now ronald acuna jr i
think i saw freddie freeman in the
background too saying you got to check
that one out it wouldn't be a manager's
review it'd be an umpire review if the
ball stays in
focus
in front of the pole clearly
foul
[Applause]
now a 2-2 pitch
he'll just take a base hit though that's
fine that's definitely fair
and aguilar as it just dies out there in
left field on his way to third
he's been a clutch hitter for him this
year six hits with runners in scoring
position
but not this time martin came back to
get him and now he's in out away
from escaping a giant mess yeah big
pitch there got sanchez to swing over
the top of the breaking ball going high
fastball maybe runner first goes ball on
the ground to dansby he'll flip to first
and call chris martin houdini he got out
of it his worst career out
sandy leone puts a charge into one this
is deep to right field and this one is
gone home run for sandy leone
and the marlins get an insurance run and
take a 5-3 lead
marlins for the last couple of innings
have so desperately looked for that
insurance run sandy
he does it all by himself green's 25th
pitch is hit down the line hit well
and aguilar adds two more
two run shot jesus aguilar
marlins blow it open in the ninth inning
if there's got to be something to be
said about two three and four in the
marlins lineup
no place to put almante this is a great
place for abraham we know how patient he
is at the plate
[Applause]
go on one pitch
hotshot fair down the third base line
that'll score two into around second
he's on his way to third and it's a
double for amante and the braves are
down one
and acuno with a third inning homer a
chance to be a ninth inning hero
high fly ball that might be deep enough
to tie it
ncrt at third there's the catch here he
comes duvall's throw it's up the line
hey now monty moves up two
oconia with a sac fly ties this game
[Applause]
that got away here comes randy
pitcher he's saved and the braves have
won it
marlon's immediately asked for a
challenge
he's out in this position right here
that i'm looking at
yeah and he's out yeah he is what a play
by leon and bass max
in a situation of every pitcher's dream
swag in line drag
braves win max freed
max freed with a pitch hit single the
braves win at 8-7 celebrate again boys
are you kidding me
take it easy on it boys he's got a pitch
tomorrow okay
as wild as this game was only fitting
that a pitcher comes off the bench and
delivers the game-winning base in